jojo was geht hier vor allem max und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
zusammen mit luca wir haben es heute was
lustiges überlegt ob jemand über den ich
immer lustige sachen oder sind wir nicht
cool und originell und zwar werden wir
sumo rausgeht er online spielen mit
ferngesteuerten autos auf einem tisch
bei sumo geht es darum ein schubs den
anderen mit seinem auto raus aus dem
lächeln
wir zeigen euch mal die karten geht
durch hier oben drauf und zwar geht es
bei spielen mit diesem auto und mit
diesem auto den spaß leute ab dafür dass
wir wirklich so kreative ideen haben
würde ich einfach sagen lasst mal 17
dann hättest du kannst sagen wir legen
los dem 32
ripley sind knapp gewonnen ohne 1
gespielt bis 3 und verlierer der
verlierer auf dem deck der verlierer
muss sein gesicht bzw seine stürmer an
die tischkante macht nur dann klickten
dann gestalten siegerauto geben den
schädel hereinkam
ich will mehr als rang steht übrigens
nur eine kameraeinstellung weil ich habe
es nicht eilig und noch mit meinem abi
ball der morgen ist ziemlich gestresst
von daher macht mit heute ausnahmsweise
weniger auf hinten
so leute runde zwei jahren die kameras
mal umgestellt und 321
es ist immer direkt alte wagen des
killer auto bitte nix mehr einfach
besser gemacht
es war viel zu teures verfahren
ja wir machen bis fünf leute sonst das
zu schnell der insgesamt 15 verlängert
haben dass wenn ich das nicht gewinnen
habe ich hier schon gefahren weil auf
den markt das 54 spiel gewinnen
313 2 für mich dass es jetzt schon
irgendwie das ding beschleunigen besser
bereitet mir macht das hat nicht nur bei
massa fahren wir ganz geradeaus das
nacheinander
weinerlich dass die reifen durchdrehen
werden die flugbahn endlos an der palast
in der 110 euro zusammengestrichen jetzt
fahrzeuge namibia machen das genauso
aber leute wir spielen uns die letzte
runde bisschen dunkler dritte nicht
optimal wir spielen jetzt gleich letzte
runde fragt weil 1 ich habe aufgegeben
die zwei zu eins für mich jetzt wie ihr
wechsel noch mal die kamera und machen
die vielleicht entscheidende runde
ja verstanden du kannst sagte ein
sprecher es geht um alles
glück auf
und während in los angeles
luca ich war zwar lieber deiner fussball
challenge ich wieder nur wie konnte es
gegen den verlieren hast du richtig
verloren gibt sich vielleicht stimmt es
gibt auf der einen kanal geprüft so
leute wie auch immer ist hier einfach
der ton ausgefallen
wir haben eigentlich nichts weiteres
gemacht als die bestrafung durchgeführt
ducati grad noch mal angesprochen dass
wir seinen kanal abonnieren sollen hhk
so da sehe ich sie ziemlich für mit
leidens fällt aus und ich war sehr
traurig dass ich verloren habe okay was
wird vorbereitet das auto wird
aufgestellt zurückgefahren und gleich
ist es soweit
bei der bestrafung im kopf tut immer
noch weh so angsterfüllte blick nach
oben auto fährt an anerkannte und
gleitet schaut euch an wie kleide mein
gott ich weiß nicht was los ist mit dem
toni überhaupt und hier habe ich mich
dann auch verabschiedet gesagt danke
dass sie dabei war als ob man das so ein
komisches video und jetzt auch ich ab
macht's gut